Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie got a bunch of
new Logan footage, let's break it down we
gotta talk about classic brown costume there's
a bunch of Legion stuff for the first episode
it's dropping this week and we got new details
on X-Men supernova the dark Phoenix project.
There's a new round of the Logan giveaway
it's for IMAX gift certificates.
All you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video be sure
to click that bell to enable alerts so you
don't miss anything.
It just shows you how bad things have gotten
so this is in Texas.
I think somewhere near the border close to
Mexico but it said 6+ years after the end
of the last X-Men film and they're fighting
over water, literally.
That's what this clip is about this person
that Logan's met V of trying to protect Professor
X that they taken in with just wants to get
water from this well in the person who owns
the land is getting really pissed off is trying
to drive them off.
Logan's response is priceless to like peacocks
the gun he says yeah I hear that a lot more
than I like to just all the times that he's
been shot remember he has a adamantine skeleton
still you see him in the amazing grace part
of the clip, just holding his claws that's
because he's gotten sold his regenerative
powers have gotten so weak that it actually
hurts him a lot more now to pop the clause
so yet he can still eat a bullet or two he
could probably eat a shotgun blast it would
take him a lot longer to heal.
That's why he's showing so many signs of where
you can see a little bit better here when
he is crawling on the ground in the middle
of this giant fight after he's been running
around clawing the hell out of people just
still obese but so much that old man Logan
persona from the comics you have to imagine
that wolverines only functionally immortal.
He's not completely immortal.
So eventually he would die of natural causes
would just take hundreds of times longer than
a normal human.
It's not quite like Deadpool's healing factor
is healing factor is almost instantaneous.
So it's a little more powerful, which is why
he still has the cancer a lot of people is
wonder that if he is the healing factor why
does he look like a normal person will it's
because his healing factor heals the cancerous
cells from before his X gene was activated.
So is healing factor just restores him to
his original state, which means that all the
tumors grow back which kind of sucks.
Speaking of which.
A lot of you spotted in Caliban were making
Deadpool joke because his face does collect
like Deadpool's face it's a very old version
of Caliban the reason he's in this movie is
because he has the ability to sense other
mutants within a 25 mile radius.
So we the ravers are forcing him to help them
hunt down the rest of mutant kind and track
down X 23 and return her to the weapon X program
or Logan and Professor X try to seek him out,
to try and find the other bands of mutants
that have managed to survive all these purges
that he's holding to live grenades in this
picture.
So this looks like it somewhere where the
rivers have captured him.
So for those that are wondering why he's in
the movie is because the ravers have been
hunting down and killing X-Men, that's also
what they did in the comics but if you were
going to do that you would need someone to
help you find all those mutants normally you
could just go to Professor X and cerebral
but Caliban is the next best option and he's
actually Stephen merchant was also in X-Men
apocalypse is a much younger version of the
character where apocalypse went to recruit
new mutants to become his horsemen.
So I do like that they're acknowledging some
X-Men history while at the same time doing
their own thing is within the X-Men universe,
but this is so far in the future that any
time they make a reference to comic book things
is really just going to be tongue-in-cheek
and speaking of Easter eggs a lot of people
were freaking out when Hugh Jackman posted
this picture and just said, the original in
the caption.
It was a picture of Wolverine in his classic
brown costume people like oh my got are we
gonna see this in the movie will be seen in
the comic book X 23 is reading he's wearing
the yellow costume, but that doesn't necessarily
guarantee that will ever see him where that
version of the costume.
Maybe somebody has a picture of them from
a long time ago and in the picture wolverines
wearing the costume and that's how we'll see
it but that aside there might just be a Wolverine
action figure inside the movie but if there's
a comic book about the X-Men and the movie
that means it is also all the other kind of
comic book merchandise that they make.
Just twist your head around.
Maybe there are X-Men films inside the X-Men
films that will be crazy.
The next big thing X-Men supernova.
So there was a synopsis the people found this
been known for a while it might have changed
but it basically says that supernova will
be dark Phoenix already.
This gathered together by Professor Charles
Xavier to protect the world the fears and
hates them the X-Men, it fought many battles
been on adventures that span galaxies grappled
enemies of limitless might, but none of this
could prepare them for the most shocking struggle
they would ever face one of their own members
Jean Gray has gained powers beyond all comprehension
in that power has corrupted her absolutely.
Now they must decide if the life of the woman
they cherish is worth the existence of the
entire universe the just blows your mind is
definitely the dark Phoenix storyline, but
that doesn't mean that they're still doing
that, because this seems like it's a little
old.
So they may have changed their plans or what
the next X-Men movie is going to be still
called supernova.
That's the working title that might change
a little.
So if we get any updates I'll post a video
about it but it just sounds like Fox is going
to be pretty quiet about what that project
is there little more open about what's going
on with new mutants and Deadpool to just because
that stuff is all been confirmed, but the
next big thing later this week Legion episode
one is going to drop its Wednesday night at
10 PM in the United States.
So be sure to check where is airing internationally
which channels on its Fox international channels.
So if you live outside the United States and
you watch say like The Walking Dead that airs
on Fox channels means that Legion will probably
be on the same channel you would normally
find The Walking Dead on its Wednesday night
it airs at the same time all over the world.
So I'll be posting my video Thursday morning
for that they dropped a whole bunch more footage
around the Super Bowl some to play those clips
here is really trippy.
You cannot run.
Perhaps instead of just lower the volume Legion
is Wednesday six so just reminder this is
going to be happening Wednesday night my video
will post Thursday morning for it.
We can decide whether or not we want to talk
about it week to week.
I think it's gonna be really cool it's only
eight episodes, so is a relatively low time
investment.
I think it's gonna be really cool though but
is gonna be a whole bunch more Logan stuff
because there's so much Super Bowl stuff that
drop and I'm still trying to get through my
next video later tonight will be for the Justice
league preview they had some pretty big teasers
inside of that.
So I'll explain what's going on in that but
there are links in the description for all
the Super Bowl stuff that I've done in case
you missed any of the videos giveaway time
Arik wall you are the new Logan giveaway winner.
Please private message me on the back end
of my channel so I can get your contact details.
There's a new round in this video I'll just
announce the winner when I post that Legion
episode 1 video on Thursday while you wait
for that you can click here for all the guardians
trailer stuff and you can click here for stranger
thing season 2 thank you so much watching
everybody let's high five I'll see the next
video!